if you want to talk about fight okay
well no you're gonna have to pay the
[ __ ] that are fighting on your
card no you don't you don't you thought
i don't know dana's gonna go well i
looked at how much you're paying the guy
jason like it's not a jake paul
promotion [ __ ] it is a jake paul
promotion but it's a jake paul it's a
it's a showtime production but it's a
jake paul fight if your headline in the
card is a jay paul fight
yeah but he but it's not up to him to
pay them like it doesn't come out of his
he could be criticized he's leaving
himself open i disagree
you don't think so
yeah i think he's leaving himself open
because i don't think he's just a worker
on the card i think he's like a partner
on the card i think of his your card is
your pay-per-view you dictate who's on
it he's going to have his friends and
training partners on the card like he
has a lot of say on what happens on that
card right like i think some of his
training partners are even on it so you
think dana would like well he didn't pay
your guys 100 percent he's not going to
say [ __ ]
you tell me dave's like he's going to
bring up fighter pay maybe get somebody
else maybe dana but somebody else would
come out and be like somebody not
important who's going to do it
some troll for dana some ufc
spokesperson
maybe ariel pops up you know what i mean
maybe
maybe show up i won't at all
maybe april maybe maybe it's andrew
maybe it is me no i mean i think it's
good that he wants them to get paid like
let [ __ ] get paid it's just an
interesting thing like the ufc the
interesting thing about jake paul is all
this like crossover like youtuber versus
this real fighter it all stops if he
gets starts on sunday all this goes away
so enjoy it right now because if he gets
starts next sunday it's over bro
it's over this fun ride ron is done but
what no matter what happens he's [ __ ]
brilliant
do you know them i do they're great i
know logan more than jake me too i'm
close with logan yeah i know jake a
little bit but they're they're brilliant
they're busy they are [ __ ] brilliant
yes and
that's why i [ __ ] with them that's why i
stick up for him for that and jake's and
i haven't really i'm talking jake maybe
one time but like
i respect what he's done and i respect
his ability
to exist with people
hating him yes a lot of people can't go
through that a lot of people can't sit
in the [ __ ] pocket and
most people need to be like they need to
be told that they're great they're
amazing etc that [ __ ] goes out
and says you could hate me and hate my
ass right to the bank and that's exactly
what he's doing correct i think the only
fuck-up he's made in this whole boxing
thing is picking tyron because
unfortunately i don't think people care
enough about tyron so jake has to carry
i disagree you think people care yes
you're talking about a former he's a ufc
hall of famer he'll be a first ballot
hall of famer he's regarded as one of
the best welterweights to ever do it he
also has good knockouts in the ufc
the thing you gotta realize about like
who would you want to fight let's start
there personality just fight person ben
askren nate diaz i mean nate i want him
to fight any dude not happening
but i want to fight that fight's not
happening sure sure but i want to fight
any diaz i want to fight ask him was
brilliant because askings of personality
asgrin promoted the [ __ ] out of that
fight dude fight week was asking and
asking only he drove pay-per-views like
crazy and he can't box so it's a good
match-up it was perfect matchup
so for who else so diaz and i'm a
personality
personality give me another guy give me
a name name a personality name somebody
who could talk shauna man what do people
uh talk about shawna mallory there's
another one so your ideas sean o'malley
keep going mike perry you like mike
perry great person i would love michael
would that be great those are fantastic
who else yes give him another one uh
conor mcgregor that'd be fun right
you like connor i don't know him versus
connor
fight so you guys just named all ufc
guys so the way this works
those guys can't touch those fights
it's against their contract it will
never happen you're never going to see
nate diaz you've never seen nick diaz
never see conor mcgregor unless conor
gets dana in with the promotion and say
hey i'm going to give you this
percentage allow me to take this fight
yeah during that's how the floyd fight
worked danny got paid yeah of course
paid paid yeah so like nate all these
guys
contracts they're not dana would never
let it happen
why not never gonna happen so the only
reason woodley and why woodley's the
perfect candidate is because he was
released he's released yeah and he's a
former champion he has knockouts he's a
hall of fame he's on paper and also it's
not a good fight for jay brandon he's on
paper a good opponent you're saying
doesn't he he doesn't build the hype
exactly we don't need the hype we don't
do we don't yeah yes we do this is going
gonna sell better than ben asking
i'm curious because he's a better
fighter than ben
ben can't box people don't care about
they do that they do in the fight
committee which is gonna buy this
pay-per-view first of all jake's now the
audience is gonna buy no matter what so
that's there so check that box the fight
community the fighter wants to see what
it makes people billionaires the casuals
makes people billionaires jake has that
jake has that jake has millions of
million subscribers they're all buying
it here's the thing
jake has he has the cat i don't know if
the fight community even the fight
community cares and it seems like i'm
talking [ __ ] about tyrone i think tyron
is actually like a good guy a nice guy
he's great it's not his fault that he
doesn't like play into the social media
antics he doesn't like but you're
missing it schultz no no what when he
fought was he a major pay-per-view draw
no no was he
actually quite the opposite were people
not interested in his fights and don't
get me wrong he has some unbelievable
[ __ ] knockouts but the problem was
fights [ __ ] him the wander boy fights
[ __ ] him and wonder boy is an exciting
[ __ ] fighter it's a clash of styles
of course nobody wants to throw et
cetera but the point is you want to have
a person who has an engaging enough
personality i mean the whole idea of 24
7 though that series that hbo started
right and now i think showtime's doing
their version yeah the countdown the
countdown
all access whatever it is the whole idea
of that is
people don't give a [ __ ] about these
guys they're just throwing punches but
they do care about them if they get to
know them they know they're having
watched all access requiredly i have not
it's [ __ ] brilliant his mom's there
it's brilliant his mom is his mom is
unbelievable she's great it's incredible
i remember after i think it was like the
usman fighter or something like that she
like hugged him and she's right she's
that is a moment that's not you're
missing it you missed you're off on this
um and this is why you are
telling you we'll see paper you know we
can bet we'll see we'll bet all i say is
this jake is going extra hard to promote
this fight he wasn't going this hard to
promote the askran fight but but here's
the thing and right as far as promotion
but the thing is for jake he can't keep
beating up guys like ben asking and nate
robinson no no he's the the fans demand
that he fight through the fight i'm a
clever woodley is his real
i'll tell you this if woodley is in the
right mindset and trained for this fight
he will beat jake let me and that's why
we're going to tune in because this is
the first time jake cannot now i want to
have a conversation about that but
again i'm not talking about his skill
his skill i've seen i know you're saying
his promotability and i'm saying we
don't need that for this but we don't
believe you don't need it i believe that
you always need it
off i think you're going to need jacob
jake you need jake can fight kyle and
it's going to break a million
pay-per-views no but
yeah you're out of your mind no no
at least a million no i don't think so
no i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so i
fought nate robinson bro
but a lot of people think that people
bought that fight to see him fight nate
that was mike tyson's card what jake did
so it was a fake mike tyson fight
against roy's job babe don't just say
that
that was the gentleman
you guys didn't know that i watched
advertising what we all watched for
tyson jones
that wasn't even a real fight what jake
did that was a fake fight
doesn't matter and you paid for it yes
roy jones wasn't even in shape or tyson
he's 50. they couldn't be punched to the
head and yes they did they punched to
that they did not punch them oh my god
this conspiracy theorist [ __ ] yes no
this is these are hiding
they couldn't punch the [ __ ] head
dude of course they were punching me oh
get out of here you really are saying
right now that that was i'm telling you
it's a gentleman's bet
it was a gentleman's bet nobody's gonna
get uh taken down nobody's getting punt
like hit to the body no one's there's
none of that there's a gentleman you
know this for a fact
what were we being boozled you bought
that for jake paul no i don't know
i didn't know he was fighting you i
think you underestimate how few black
people know who jake paul is before he
started boxing i still don't know the
difference between jake and logan
here let me give you a perfect example
and i love you and
you're the best show you're not the
audience bro no no like they
but in the way that and i always say
this but like white people know about
one baby right it's not a little baby or
the baby we just have one person it's
just baby right
black people have one paw i agree i hear
it all the time they're like is it floyd
didn't know who he was fighting
you